idiot get in here what if I'm stepping
down as the head of YouTube I'm sick and
tired of this how hard can it be to make
the platform better we just want fewer
unskippable ads bring back the dislike
button and put shorts into its own
section on a channel page we did that
already but people just want to focus on
the fact that we did a bad thing they
just want to stay mad they just want to
stay mad oh the algorithm is suppressing
My Views maybe you just make videos
David that wouldn't seem to personal
maybe anyways I'm out and my replacement
is in hi I am CEO it was like a pretty
thankless job how did you find someone
who wanted to take your place I have
been in a coma for 20 years oh no I
can't wait to be in charge of companies
this is wrong does he even know what
YouTube is well I assume a small
plumbing company okay well at least you
get paid a lot that's just really ooh
what is a cardi B